everyone thanks for watching here at the
social media corner the Oscar leader
series i'm mateus lipkins head of
digital at the forum signing off now it
is also my last day here at the forum
not pictured here is Georgie pocho can't
can come but and ice under main was here
in the corner for the past five days how
many videos do 162 videos I well done
that is a record thank you very much
chris is gonna take hours for words yes
we'll be doing the same in Mexico so
look forward to that and we have
tremendous Facebook live session and
tell find desert give it was a
tremendous producer and I think it's
been a tremendous success absolutely
thank you very much for watching and see
you soon thank you